libération d'un otage belge au liban
après l'intervention du colonel kadhafi
jan cools et ce soir à damas long
déjeuner à dance contre le président
mitterrand et les valises à la france
est engagée à soutenir économiquement la
pologne chine les trois premières
condamnations à mort annoncée
aujourd'hui à shanghai
mikhaïl gorbatchev et ronald reagan et
rim l'inde et l'autre leur inquiétude
quasi-stabilité des salaires en france
en 88 le smic pourrait être augmenté en
juillet voilà monsieur bonsoir ian cole
c'est ce soir un homme libre
le médecin belge qui travaillait au
liban pour une organisation humanitaire
norvégienne avait été enlevé il y a un
an et trois semaines il a été libéré ce
matin sur intervention semble-t-il du
colonel kadhafi il est apparu très ému
amaigri mais en bonne santé apparemment
et dans une brève déclaration il a
remercié à la fois l'organisation
palestinienne d'abou nidal et le colonel
libyen
il est parti ce soir pour damas
accompagné d'une délégation
ministérielle belge les conditions de sa
libération provoque déjà des remous
politiques en belgique
il reste à ce jour 16 otages occidentaux
détenus au liban en chine
la télévision a annoncé aujourd'hui les
premières condamnations à mort depuis le
début de la répression il ya douze jours
et elle a montré les trois jeunes gens
écoutent ans à shanghai le verdict de la
cour de justice populaire
le commentaire de l'un de nos envoyés
spéciaux prudent le dreff et lors du
journal télévisé que les chinois ont
appris les premières condamnations à
mort liée aux troubles de ces dernières
semaines
les trois jeunes hommes avaient
participé à l'incendié d'un train à
shanghai
il y avait mis le feu après que le
conducteur est écrasée 6 étudiants qui
tentaient d'arrêter la motrice reconnus
coupables de destructions de matériels
de transport public
sont exécutés conformément à la loi
d'une balle dans la nuque
une belle que leur famille devra
rembourser à l'armée ils ont été jugés
selon les procédures habituelles de la
justice chinoise est disposé d'avocat
mais il ne fait pas de doute que leur
condamnation à la peine capitale alors
qu'ils ne sont responsables d'aucune
mort à une fonction exemplaire des
condamnations qui augure mal de l'avenir
des personnes arrêtées à pékin est
accusé d'avoir tué ou blessé des soldats
les interpellations se poursuivent
d'ailleurs toujours au même rythme
par dizaines chaque jour grâce au
travail de sape de la propagande
la chine est retourné à l'ère de la
délation qu'elle avait oublié depuis la
fin de la révolution culturelle
l'association humanitaire française
médecins sans frontières a réussi à
cheminer à pékin du matériel médical qui
sera famille dans un premier temps un
dispensaire germano chinois tandis que
quelques diplomates chinois font
défection à l'étranger à pékin les
ambassades des états unis et du canada
ont réouvert leurs consulats depuis hier
quelques 200 chinois en grande majorité
des jeunes ils font la queue dans
l'espoir d'obtenir un visa
leur nombre ne serait pas vraiment plus
élevé que d'habitude
à hong kong en revanche hong kong les
consulats étrangers sont pris d'assaut
par des chinois candidats à
l'immigration il ne croit manifestement
plus aux chances de la colonie
britannique qui dans huit ans sera sous
la férule de pékin pour la première fois
depuis le début de la répression en
chine michael gorbatchev s'est
publiquement exprimé sur la question
c'était à bonn tout à l'heure à
l'occasion d'une conférence de presse où
il dressait le bilan de sa visite en
allemagne fédérale
gilles rabin la chine
il aurait sans aucun doute préféré ne
pas avoir à en parler
hirai berbatov a justifié le silence de
moscou après les massacres de tiananmen
par un manque d'information suffisante
malgré tout pour le numéro un soviétique
on ne peut pas soupçonner les étudiants
chinois de mener
révolutionner votre question sur
laquelle le silence de michail
gorbatchev avait été remarquée est
soulignée depuis le début de sa visite
en allemagne de l'ouest
le mur de berlin rien n'est éternel
sujet soleil s'est il contenté de
déclarer le mur tombera qu'en
disparaîtront les conditions qu'ils ont
fait une analyse pour le reste succès
total visite historique tournant dans
les relations entre les deux pays
michail berbatov a manifesté autant d'
enthousiasme que les allemands de
l'ouest pour qualité ces quatre jours de
visite en rfa le monde est sorti de la
guerre froide même s'il reste encore
quelques courants d'air réfrigérant a
conclu le numéro un soviétique
devant ces ouvriers de la ruhr qui lui
ont réservé une longue ovation et dont
il a célébré l'intelligence la
compétence et la discipline
un rêve pour gorbatchev qui affirmait
dans cette usine de dortmund que le
capitalisme n'avait ni le monopole de la
pluralité d'opinion ni le monopole de
l'économie de marché
et ce soir les autorités de l'allemagne
de l'est se disent satisfaites de la
visite du numéro un soviétique à l'ouest
un sondage intéressant de la sofres pour
le figaro magazine trouve qu'en france
nous sommes nous aussi touché par la
gorby manille - cependant que les
allemands 51% des français pense le plus
grand bien du numéro un soviétique
contre 41% pour george bush on ne peut
massacrer une idée on peut criblé de
balles l'espérance d'un peuple c'est en
ces termes que l'ancien président
américain ronald reagan à condamner la
répression en chine en inde reagan qui
est à paris pour trois jours a été reçu
cet après midi à l'académie des sciences
morales et politiques en présence de
jérôme baugnies succès du coup plus
reagan quai de conti et moi sous la
coupole pour la réception de
l'ex-président américain
le sixième depuis 1801 il rejoint auprès
de ça car au pire one carlos les membre
associé étranger de l'académie des
sciences morales et politiques
je n'aurai qu'à vos mais qu'une série
est nombreux après une tentative
difficile en hommage à la francophonie
ronald reagan poursuit dans sa langue
pour évoquer en cette année les droits
de l'homme les étudiants si nos propres
perplexité face à cette irruption
inaccoutumée de l'actualité à l'institut
mais admiration devant ce jeune couple
de retraités toujours aussi amoureux
tout va bien la vie des immortels peut
continuer
il avait vraiment beaucoup pas se dire
le président mitterrand et les valaisans
ont déjeuné ensemble aujourd'hui est
dense un long déjeuner le général jean
jouzel ce qui lui avait ce matin
accompagné le chef de l'état français
dans le fief de solidarité chatte
merlino côte à côte en fin de matinée le
général joseph qui cette fois en
uniforme et le président de la
république sont allés déposer une gerbe
au monument de bester plater à gdansk
c'est ici qu lieu le 1er septembre 1939
le premier acte de guerre de l'allemagne
nazie hommage rendu par les deux chefs
d'état à l'époque où la france et la
pologne étaient alliés et combattait le
même adversaire
ce souvenir est souvent évoquée dans les
discours officiels et dans les
entretiens privés
chacun ici s'efforce de renouer les
liens chaleureux qui ont uni les deux
pays
tout au long de leur histoire
aujourd'hui le président françois
mitterrand s'appuie sur ce passé afin
que la france et la pologne
chacune de leur côté s'efforce de
rapprocher l'europe de l'ouest et
l'europe de l'est
c'est dans cet esprit qu un effort
exceptionnel est annoncé hier soir la
france accepte de repousser à plus tard
le remboursement de 7 milliards de
francs que lui doit la pologne
et puis la présence du président
français permettent ici d'une certaine
manière de contribuer à la
réconciliation entre les polonais je
suis surpris que le général viennent à
gdansk aujourd'hui lors des autres
visites officielles
on ne le voyait pas il faut absolument
des contacts entre pays capitalistes
socialiste c'est la même heure
je suis content que pour une nouvelle
fois la france et la pologne se
rapproche de fait le président françois
mitterrand bénéficie d'une situation
tout à fait particulière car il fut le
premier chef d'état occidental à
accueillir le général jaruzelski après
la proclamation de l'état de guerre et
il fut le premier chef d'état occidental
à obtenir des autorités polonaises
qu'elle laisse sortir du territoire
lech walesa cela lui permet aujourd'hui
d'avoir des relations parent
hier directes et franches avec ces deux
hommes car aussitôt après avoir quitté
le général jaruzelski le président
mitterrand était reçue par lech walesa
avec lui il est allé se recueillir
devant le célèbre monument aux trois
croix monument à la mémoire de la
révolte ouvrière de 1970 révolte suivie
d'une répression qui fit un millier de
morts
françois mitterrand auparavant s'était
longuement entretenu avec les cheveux
les a lors d'un déjeuner entretien ayant
permis d'aller plus avant dans la
compréhension de la situation
exceptionnelle que connaît aujourd'hui
la pologne élections européennes on a
voté aujourd'hui dans cinq pays de la
communauté
il faisait beau partout mais la
participation a été inégal contre toute
attente participation en hausse en
irlande et surtout en grande-bretagne
malgré les pronostics la participation
se situerait là-bas entre 40 et 50%
on a moins voté quand 84 ans 79 au
danemark aux pays-bas ici en espagne
l'abstention en espagne devrait dépasser
les 40%
les résultats du vote d'aujourd'hui ne
seront connus que dimanche soir après le
vote des autres pays membres en
allemagne fédérale après l'allégresse et
les festivités de la visite de mikhaïl
gorbatchev la campagne pour les
élections européennes reprend son cours
le scrutin aura donc lieu dimanche comme
chez nous la vraie inconnue le score de
l'extrême droite qui dans les dernières
élections locales avaient remporté un
certain succès philippe rochon
les nazis dehors chaque rassemblement de
l'union du peuple allemand la dv eu
d'extrême droite est fortement contestée
pourtant rien ne semble arrêter la
montée de ce petit parti qui espère
passer la barre des 5% aux européennes
la dvi s'est allié avec le parti néo
nazi npd pour obtenir du renfort
mais ces militants rejette cette
étiquette qu'on leur donne je ne suis
pas nazi même si nous sommes nés dans
cette période nazie qui a existé je ne
le sens pas nazi mais allemande de droit
et je suis pour cette allemagne l'a pas
celle que les rouges là bas veulent
représenter la dvi a déjà dépassé les
chrétiens démocrates dans cette ville de
wolfisheim à 30 km de francfort
frappés par le chômage et qui a peur de
l'immigration
nous ne sommes pas contre l'europe mais
pour une europe des patries libre comme
de gaulle l'a proposé mais nous sommes
contre ce monstre de la cee qui fait que
les allemands payent le plus dans la
communauté et que les autres encaissent
même
les nazis dehors c'est encore ce slogan
qui harcèle le chef des républicains
chez nous leurs pendants ces
rassemblements politiques
au point que pour obtenir le calme il
doit faire chanter à ses partisans
l'hymne national allemand
j'étais soldat dans la waffen ss mais je
n'en ai pas honte
mais chez nous vers fait surtout sa
campagne contre l'immigration il n'est
pas possible d'importer une guerre
civile en allemagne que les tamouls se
bat chez eux mais pas à bonn les
républicains ont voulu prendre leurs
distances des formations léonaise ils
ont déjà fait entrer 11 députés ou
sénateurs berlin et il compte sur 20%
des voix aux élections européennes
l'extrême droite pourtant ne se présente
pas unie à ces élections mais un slogan
rassemble ses partisans l'allemagne
d'abord en france le feuilleton continue
je veux parler des embarras du
bicentenaire qui continue de nourrir
polémique s'est démentie alors qu'on se
dise les autoroutes d'accès à paris ne
seront pas fermés à la circulation pour
les cérémonies
seul le parcours orly paris fera l'objet
de restrictions de circulation d'autres
cas ce pauvre 26 chefs d'état de a comme
allemagne de l'ouest à z comme au
zimbabwe vont atterrir ici les 12 13 et
14 juillet sécurité oblige
quand les cortèges officiels vont aller
sur paris l'autoroute du sud sera fermée
entre 5 et 10 minutes avant chaque
passage est réouverte cinq minutes après
le convoi pour le moment difficile
d'évaluer la durée de ces embarras le
tronçon paris province n'est pas touché
par ces mesures et pour le voyageur
lambda qui arriverait à paris ce jour-là
sauvé il y a le fameux numéro vert qui
théoriquement le renseignera sur le
libre accès de cette bretelle
vraiment aucune idée mais il faut déjà
compter sur un retard de une à trois
heures
autre déception le louvre refoulera ses
vingt mille visiteurs quotidiens entre
le 11 et le 15 juillet la joconde
réservera sont ambigus sourire aux chefs
d'état du sommet des pays industrialisés
si les 1000 employés jubile de ce congé
inespéré d'autres beaucoup plus nombreux
sont très mécontents ont fermé l'ours
est un petit peu en dedans parce que
c'est un peu notre outil de travail
je pense que c'est après ta pour les
touristes vont être à paris durant cette
période même si à dessert d'état je
pense que nous deux jours ne suffit
largement cette fermeture
en tout cas les puissants de ce monde
auront le privilège de contempler une
mona lisa peut-être un peu plus intime
3091 des tenues très précisément vont
bénéficier des mesures de grâce
collective à l'occasion du 14 juillet
parmi eux bien sûr aucun terroriste et
aucun condamné à perpétuité dans les
prisons cette amnistie déçoit et le
mécontentement gronde en gaz du rejet
certains d'entre eux attendaient des
années de remise de peine le total de
leurs grâces ne pourra excéder 9 mois
déception est mauvaise humeur dans les
prisons françaises
à l'image des détenus de marseille ce
soir commis hier aux baumettes
ils sont six ans a refusé de regagner
leur cellule protestation pacifique
contre l'insuffisance des mesures
d'amnistié en cette période du
bicentenaire l'année dernière 6000
détenus étaient sortis de prison
cette année ils seront moitié moins à
bénéficier de la grâce
une grâce cependant jugé raisonnable par
le garde des sceaux
cet après midi à l'assemblée nationale a
augmenté 7 sort je pense que la grâce
qui est envisagée est une grâce
équilibré normale qui ne fera pas sortir
des gens par vagues importantes et qui
atteindra peut-être dans les quatre
premiers moins que 3000 personnes
et encore ce n'est pas certain
certitude en revanche aucun des détenus
condamnés à perpétuité évadés ou
convaincu de terrorisme ne bénéficiera
de cette clémence collective une grâce
qui exclut donc à double titre le
libanais anis naccache nakache jugé pour
terrorisme est condamné à perpétuité
après l'attentât manqué contre l'ancien
premier ministre du chah d'iran les
salaires en france sont restés à peu
près stables en 88 c'est ce que prouvent
les chiffres publiés par l'insee
mais le smic pourrait bénéficier le mois
prochain d'un coup de pouce
claire chazal jean de gérard leclerc les
salariés du privé ont gagné l'an dernier
07 % de pouvoir d'achat ils ont ainsi
été traités à peu près comme les
fonctionnaires et s'en sont en tout cas
mieux tiré en 88 camps 80 cette année où
leurs gains réels avaient été quasi
nulle ce sont les ouvriers qui ont le
plus profité des hausses et l'écart
entre ouvriers et cadres c'est un peu
resserré en 88
il est aujourd'hui de aa3 à noter que la
moitié des français gagnent moins de six
mille neuf cent francs par mois
mais entre les smicards le bas de
l'échelle et les plus hauts revenus
le trou s'est creusé car fait sans
précédent depuis 79 le smig a décroché
en 88
il a même perdu 0 6% pouvoir d'achat
notamment à cause du ralentissement de
l'inflation
il faut revaloriser le smic il a pris du
retard sur les prix sur les autres
salaires et on puisse la situation
financière et l'économie va mieux
il faut donc que les spica profite aussi
de ses résultats sur la fiche de paye
quand les syndicats réclament un coup de
pouce sur le smic au 1er juillet il
trouve un certain écho dans les
recommandations du président de la
république pour un meilleur partage des
fruits de la croissance
mais ils ont aussi en face d'eux le
grand argentier pierre bérégovoy qui
craint comme la peste les effets de
contagion sur une inflation qui aura
atteint dès le premier semestre
les deux et quelques pour cent prévus
pour l'année face à cette double menace
d'un dérapage social ou inflationnistes
michel rocard devrait opter pour une
voie moyenne celle d'un léger coup de
pouce sans pouvoir d'achat de l'ordre de
deux dixièmes de point
s'ajoutant à l'indexation automatique
sur les prix au total une augmentation
voisine de 2% en comparable à celle du
salaire horaire
et qui permettrait au smic pour le
bicentenaire de franchir la barre des
5000 francs bruts
le mouvement de grève dans les crèches
parisiennes continuer s'accentue pour le
plus grand embarras des parents près
d'un agent sur deux était en grève
aujourd'hui une grève suspendu demain
mais reconduite lundi il avait aidé les
environ 180 crèches et haltes-garderies
sur 300 sont restées fermées aujourd'hui
à paris
réunis ce matin en assemblée générale le
personnel en grève campe sur ses
positions
il réclame 250 à 350 francs de plus par
mois et des recrutements au niveau de la
ville de paris a de gros problèmes
d'ordre d'effectifs qui se fait
actuellement il manque plus de 90 postes
budgétaires d'auxiliaire de puériculture
et beaucoup de fausses aussi devenu
triste jardin d'enfants faut bien voir
c'est un personnel jeune qui a des
maternités qui a des enfants en bas âge
qui sont souvent malades et que les
remplacements ne sont pas assurés dans
les crèches le salaire moyen est de 5500
francs respectueux et qualification
souvent imprécis une situation que les
parents dénoncent eux aussi beaucoup
soutiennent les grévistes et organisent
entre des tours de garde mais ça ne se
fait pas sans mal
on essaie de faire un relais quand
c'était mercredi est la maman de robin
ne travaille pas donc
assurés de mercredi moi je me suis déjà
arrêté à lundi le papa de robin s'est
arrêté mardi dernier et aujourd'hui ça
va être une alternance entre mois la
maman de steve est le papa de steve qui
va jouer à gaza cet après midi avec eux
ont jonglé et on perd chaque fois une
journée de salaire
qu'en pensent les bébés qui ont horreur
de la routine sont ravis ces cas quel
beau baiser après les dégraissages
l'embauchent un signe de santé pour
renault véhicules industriels
éric perrin renault véhicules
industriels embauchera au total 500
personnes cette année la moitié de ces
recrutements ayant déjà été réalisées
le seul constructeur français de camions
et d'autocars avait dû réduire ses
effectifs pour redevenir bénéficiaire en
cette filiale de la régie renault
confirme ainsi son redressement
les chantiers navals janot couronnais
exportateurs de l'année le constructeur
vendéen de bateaux de plaisance a reçu
aujourd'hui l'oscar de l'exportation
décerné par le nouvel économiste
en quatre ans jeannot augmenté de 91 %
son chiffre d'affaires à l'exportation
recul du déficit commercial américain 53
milliards de francs en avril contre 67
en mars
ce résultat considérés comme bons
s'explique en grande partie par une
baisse des importations
il correspond aux prévisions des
analystes il faut coordonner le
rapatriement volontaire des boat people
mais à terme on admet bien le principe
d'un rapatriement forcé tel est le
résultat ambigu de la conférence
internationale sur les réfugiés à dos
chinois qui s'est terminée hier hd sur
un divorce entre les positions
britanniques d'un côté françaises et
américaines de l'autre paris et
washington s'opposent au principe même
du rapatriement forcé qui contraindrait
des centaines de milliers de vietnamiens
à retourner dans un pays qu'ils ont
voulu quitter à tout prix c'est un
document que nous vous proposons ce soir
un document signé pascal lebovits si
pendant un an il a suivi un petit garçon
de 7 ans un petit vietnamien des
philippines jusqu en autriche
ses parents n'avaient pas assez d'argent
pour partir ils avaient mis leur fils
seul sur une barque pour traverser la
mer de chine moonboots dans le
dictionnaire on trouve cette définition
chaussures spécialement adaptées à la
marche sur la lune
il est déjà loin ce 12 avril coin était
parmi les 54 vietnamien qui fuit ce jour
là leur pays
il a laissé là bas ses parents ses
frères ses soeurs
oui
ma peau
pourtant le rêve c'est d'abord la
précarité d'un camp de réfugiés et la
survit grâce à l'aide alimentaire de
l'onu alors que l'occident se ferme de
plus en plus aux réfugiés et l'espoir
est là au bout de la grippe mais déçu
par les avions la sélection de ceux qui
pourront partir est impitoyable sans
jules quan a cette chance de n'attendre
que 100 jours
après quelques heures de vol tout a
basculé voici l'autriche et la casquette
de ce que l'on entourent d'attention
à voir
mamma mia
non six mois ont passé sur l'autre
planète et quan est presque devenu un
écolier comme les autres de cette
banlieue de vienne où il habite
désormais avec son nom
au début toutes les petites filles
venaient s'asseoir à côté de lui pour
l'aider et lui expliquer avec des images
mais il est très doué pour apprendre et
de plus avec le temps il est de moins en
moins timides n'ont rien fait de son
mandat il était nominé comme ça
comment connecter houllier
maintenant qu'on y est pourquoi ne
l'essentiel biais d'ailleurs cette
lettre et de son père il et rééduquer
là-bas en prison pour un prétendu trafic
de médicaments
madame cause boutboul a été entendu pour
une deuxième fois aujourd'hui au
tribunal du havre
elle est inculpé depuis une semaine
d'homicide volontaire isabelle steiss
j'ai des révélations à faire aurait
confié marie élisabeth construite bull
avant de se rendre cet après midi au
palais de justice du havre où elle était
entendue par le juge
ollier jusqu'à présent son système de
défense en consistait à nier
systématiquement les accusations
formulées contre elle
la prison l'aurait-elle près réfléchir
ou bien changer d'avis peut-être mais ce
serait en même temps négliger deux
éléments nouveaux apparus dans le
dossier il y a d'abord un chauffeur de
taxi parisiens qui avaient l'habitude de
transporter madame pour ce coup de boule
interrogés tout récemment il aurait
formellement reconnu bruno dassin qui a
le représentant de commerce assassiné au
havre et il aurait confirmé que madame
cruise boutboul et bruno d'assac se
connaissaient déjà
quand le gendre de madame france
football l'avocat parisien jacques
perron a été assassiné
et puis depuis quelques jours il est
beaucoup question d'une valise ou d'une
mallette ayant appartenu à bruno d'assac
cette mallette que des témoins ont vu
dans l'appartement de gaza qui a disparu
c'est un proche de dassa qu on dit même
un intime prénommé françois qui l'aurait
emporté
alors où est passée cette mallette
at-elle été détruites
quel était son contenu c'est ce que le
juge et les enquêteurs aimeraient bien
savoir un mètre sous la coupole jean
denis bredin avocats écrivains a été
élue cet après-midi ou fauteuils de
marguerite yourcenar à l'académie
française
élu au premier tour pas de succession en
revanche aujourd'hui pour thierry
monnier
terminons en musique qui grâce à paul
c'est mme simons en garfunkel et
s'enrichissent robinson le compositeur
américain donnera demain soir à bercy
son unique concert parisien avant d'être
le 6 juillet prochain à fréjus un
concert très africain jacques dufour
depuis cinq ans date de la sortie de
l'album gouès landes paul simmons ancien
partenaire d' art cars neufs qu'elle est
devenu l'ambassadeur de la musique
africaine
l'une des choses positives de l'album
gouès landes c'est d'avoir permis une
rencontre entre deux communautés musical
qui ne se côtoyaient pas alors qu'elles
peuvent s'enrichir mutuellement
cette musique sud africaine à qui paul
simmons donne beaucoup lui a il faut le
dire permis de retrouver son second sous
enthousiastes ils considèrent qu'elle
apporte aujourd'hui au rock ce que le
reggae lui apporter y est la musique
sud-africaine a réussi à s'imposer un
peu partout il ya maintenant une demande
une envie formidable qui n'existait pas
il ya quelques années
demain soir à bercy paul simmons
l'africain chantera en compagnie de ray
pire ils prince de johannesbourg de
l'e10 miss black mambazo les champions
du macumba et de miriam makeba
football victoire de l'information si on
a décidé la cour d'appel de paris la
guerre du football entre tf1 et antenne
2 est terminé
tf1 conserve son exclusivité mais en
dehors a désormais le droit de diffuser
des extraits de matchs dans les journaux
et les magazines sportifs comme stade 2
en mentionnant bien sûr l'origine des
images
seul reste à déterminer le temps des
extraits qui pourront être ainsi
difficile voilà très vite encore les
rapports du tiercé qui s'est couru à
vincennes
aujourd'hui à l'arrivée donc le 12 le 6
et le 5-5 rang dans l'ordre rapporte
3815 points dans un ordre différent 763
francs le kart est maintenant 12 6 5 19
5 francs rapporte 100 5150 francs et
dans un ordre différent 8760 de francs
50 voilà laurent cabrol va vous parler
du temps de demain dans un instant et
puis à 22h20 ne manquez pas en direct de
varsovie du siège même de la diète le
parlement polonais édition spéciale avec
l'autre ayant bien sûr qui nous parlera
de la vie et des problèmes de société en
pologne et puis henri sannier vous
donnera les dernières informations vers
23h40 très bonne soirée sur antenne 2 à
demain matin
e
à